what do we need to know about these
batteries how big of a breakthrough is
this well I think you know I would
submit the what Elon Musk once the
American dream to deal on musk is a
chicken in every pot a Tesla in every
garage
powered by solar panels on the roof
through one of these power wall
batteries so you know up until now you
could have solar panels on your roof
that's gonna be feeding into the grid
this is a way to store that power at
your house you could use it when energy
prices spiked you could use it if the
grid were to go offline if there were a
storm on earthquake or some other
natural disaster utilities want to use
it for kind of the same reasons but on a
bigger scale they want to be able to use
all of this new alternative energy store
it and then send it out to people when
they need it look it sounds great but
help me understand how new this is is
this a totally pioneering new technology
or as Elon Musk entering a crowded field
where he's going out stiff competition I
talk to analysts about 500 companies
that have been doing this but Tesla's
very well positioned to do in a
different way I want to point to one
statistic I looked at some research from
a company called Navigant in in Boulder
Colorado and right now this industry's
worth about 605 million dollars by the
year 2024 it could be a 21 billion
dollar industry so there's a lot of I'm
not a musk fan I think he's way out
front here I think he's hit the ball out
of the park and the initial foray he's
got Amazon as a joint partner honest
with others is this about new
lithium-ion chemistry is this about the
scalability or is this just about taking
out American electric utilities make all
of the above and what he's been able to
do very effectively is get a lot of
longevity a lot of life out of these
batteries that he's put in cars and he's
made no secret of fact that he wants to
are they gonna burn up like the lithium
battery had some trouble with that of
course if you had trouble with his back
Tesla has as well so they built this
Giga factory building this Giga factory
factory of scalability David girl or is
it a new technology a new chemistry I
can't get this I think they're
continuing to work on the technology but
yeah the factory's not done yet and I
think it's something that a lot of
people have wondered about is he's come
out with this this release he said you
can get this in your house by the end of
the summer to be able to build all these
batteries both for the cars and for
houses and for utilities company that's
very ambitious and we'll have to see if
that said if that can happen well
certainly mr. musk is one who is plenty
ambition ambition